She's inside me, and she's angry.
You're friend, she's a meta. And not one of the friendly ones.
She's sick, she's not thinkin' straight.
She is a bloody menace.
knock her out!
Caitlin, what are you doing?
I'm not gonna fight you.
You keep messing with everyone's lives.
Shoot Her!
You did this to ME!
You made me cold-hearted, Barry.
The Flash, All New this Tuesday at 8/7 Central on The CW
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so new flash footage
lets break it down they're Finally doing Killer
Frost I really wish they would call the episode
the winter soldier, but it would been sued
out of existence by marble so you can kinda
see what they're doing here it's kind of like
a version of Captain America Civil War where
Caitlin is the winter soldier you can even
transpose dialogue from the Civil War trailer,
on to this he's my friend.
So was I. Sorry.
Tony were like the flash goes Rogue and punches
Julian when he orders him to take Caitlin
down so as not quite 100% it have to be Cisco
that the flash were punching if it were really
Captain America Civil War, but that is basically
what they're going for Caitlin goes rogues,
the team tries to save her, but the question
is is like what pushes her over the edge and
why is it that she's going evil like Cisco
got powers and even though you know he's maybe
a little emotionally repressed is not evil
like you just use his powers whenever he needs
to, so what is it that's happening inside
Caitlin's mind that this other Killer Frost
personality is slowly taking over they might
explain that in the next couple of episodes
like as they kinda build her Killer Frost
persona out this year like she's different
from the previous Killer Frost that we've
seen before but in the trailer she says she's
inside me she's really angry.
So what I think is is that Killer Frost is
just like all this repressed anger that Caitlin
has and is just slowly manifesting in this
way, but she does actually have legit split
personalities so hopefully they'll explain
a little bit better either in this episode
or after the midseason finale you can kind
of see like the basic arc is that Caitlin
is out trying to help on a case and something
happens to just like make her snap while she's
working with Julian she freezes his arm that
she confronts him later like I'm a meta-like
how dare you hate metas.
So we all know that he's kind of prejudice
against them now or lease he hates the ones
that he thinks are misusing their powers so
that probably doesn't help that he's badmouthing
metas in front of Caitlin see you can see
or hear showing her powers off but now you
know Captain America Civil War twist.
Barry punches Julian to save Caitlin.
Now he becomes a fugitive meaning that Joe
and other detective at the police station
will have to go after the flash unless there's
some big twist, the team flash is able to
pull off.
So depending on how they handle things Julian
might be going after team flash after this
episode so this can be really interesting
for Barry and Julian scenes after this because
Julian will be like will the flash is a criminal
we have to go after him but Barry will slough
to work at the police station with him and
then you wonder what's can happen when Julian
finds out that Barry is the flash he'll hate
him even more for lying to him this whole
time.
Plus Barry will kind of be a criminal so if
you remember back during season one we get
the teaser for Killer Frost is very was going
back the first time to save his mother we
saw Barry sitting in prison that might be
what this is that might be how Barry ends
up in iron Heights prison let me know what
you guys think of this very Captain America
winter soldier type twist for Caitlin I do
like what it means for the dynamic of the
group it deftly creates a lot of drama in
an interesting way like it's not super.
So be like she just completely loses her shipment
like oh my God how we can the save our friend
here I think that a lot better job servicing
at least Caitlin's arc, there's a lot of other
characters that they have the get to like
you can see there doing stuff with Joe the
kind trying to do something interesting with
Barry and Iris, but Caitlin's arc now doesn't
have anything to do with her relationship
status or the fact that she's a woman, so
that is one of the reasons why most excited
for her story.
I mean, in addition to the fact that she is
a really cool, comic book character in the
costume from last.
That like every kinda talk a little bit about
her future costume.
That's from a potential future the not so
distant future, so is not like years and years
away based on what's happening right now is
to the gonna try and change the future but
this is actually a better look at it like
they color tuned it so that is like all blue
you can really see it.
That will.
This is what it looks like in broad daylight
was Caitlin heavy as these last couple of
episodes have been you can expect in future
seasons for them to do this with the other
characters to like the other side characters
so the really cool thing is that were not
even at the midseason finale.
So they have like the whole back half of the
season to deal with more Killer Frost stuff
this is really just the beginning like even
though it's been seven episodes.
They're just getting started with some of
the big stuff we just met Savitar were just
meeting Killer Frost.
We don't even know who Doctor Alchemy is yet
although I think most of us have a pretty
solid theory, but Dr. alchemy will be unmasked
so to speak in the midseason finale.
So you had to a couple more weeks to find
out what's going on with that of the DC giveaway
still going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
It's a $20 Amazon gift card.
There is a new episode of Arrow tonight that
I'll post they're introducing a huge comic
book character it's a mega twist that's right
out of the comics so make sure you watch it
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my flash episode 6 Easter Eggs
and you can click here for the Trailer for
the 4 night crossover, thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!